we can all appreciate a grim ending if
the movie calls for it but not every
film needs to be a downer that's a
lesson quite a few filmmakers have
learned the hard way a surprising number
of classic films and the modern-day
blockbusters additionally came equipped
with far bleaker finales but those sad
scenes were stripped away for something
a little more lighthearted or at least a
little less depressing here are a few
beloved films that originally had much
darker endings 10 Cloverfield Lane well
10 Cloverfield Lane was successful with
audiences and critics alike many people
were upset with the film's final moments
after spending most of the film locked
in a bunker with crazy Howard Michele
finally escapes only to find herself
under attack by aliens
come on it was a complete 180 and a lot
of moviegoers found the ending outs of
plays with the rest of the movie but
it's got some seriously good undertones
as film critic Tasha Robinson explains
10 Cloverfield Lane is really a film
about domestic abuse and Michelle is a
victim who's constantly running from a
problem thanks to the controversial
ending
Michelle is able to defeat her
adversaries and overcome her habit of
running and the long-term effects of
abuse the ending is a major victory for
Michelle and the one that wasn't in the
original screenplay in the first draft
of the script which was originally
titled the cellar
Michelle breaks out of the bunker and
drives to Chicago hoping to find her
family
but when she finally arrives she
discovers the city has been mysteriously
destroyed the end she never knows if the
city was obliterated by aliens or nuked
by the Russians and neither do we
the film ends right there with the Windy
City nothing but a big pile of ashes
Robinson calls this an impersonal and
cynical ending and evidently the
producers a bad robot thought the same
thing after buying the script they hire
Damien Chazelle who wrote and directed
whiplash and la-la-land
to punch up the script and give Michelle
a happier ending in which she defeats
both a literal and figurative demons
American sniper clint eastwood's
american sniper isn't exactly what you
call in a b-movie but the original
script took it several notches deeper
into the pressing territory in real-life
Chris Kyle was killed at a shooting
range in February 2013
so since his tragic death was such a
pivotal part of the Chris Kyle story why
didn't it make the final cut of Clint
Eastwood's movie about his life well
according to screenwriter Jason Hall his
death was supposed to be in the film but
a few days after the incident Kyle's
Widow Cort Eastwood and actor Bradley
Cooper with a favor as Hall explained he
called and said this is going to be how
my children remember their father so I
want you to get it right hoping to honor
her request the creative group behind
the movie considered five different
endings before finally deciding to show
Kyle heading to the infamous shooting
range with Ralph before fading to black
all
explain the decision by saying in the
end I think we felt that this was a film
about Chris's life and not about his
death training day Denzel Washington
picks up his second Oscar for his
performance as Detective Alonzo Harris
in 2001 training day one of the most
corrupt cops to ever grace a silver
screen
Harris was declared the 50th greatest
villain of all time by the American Film
Institute King Kong ain't got hardly so
at the end of the film when Harris has
finally gunned down by the Russian mafia
moviegoers knew he'd gotten his just
desserts but the original training day
screenplay actually had Harris surviving
living to terrorize Snoop Dogg another
day after Washington accepted the part
he decided that Alonzo had to bite the
bullet like a whole lot of bullets
in an interview with dr. Todd void of
the USC School of Cinematic Arts
Washington explained that when he read
the ending he was not having it
thankfully he got his wish and Alonso
got a glorious jazz scene true romance
written by Quentin Tarantino true
romance tells a story of Clarence a
lonely film geek who falls in love with
a prostitute named Alabama the two ends
up accidentally getting involved with
the mob at the end of the movie Clarence
and Alabama find themselves in the
middle of a gunfight with the Mafia on
one side and the cops on the other well
Clarence does take a bullet our heroes
managed to take the money and run
settling in Mexico and giving audiences
an upbeat ending however this wasn't
Tarantino's original vision at first the
young screenwriter had a Clarence died
in the climactic bloodbath forcing
Alabama to grab the money and leave a
husband body behind but director Tony
Scott was so enamored with these two
characters that he asked Tarantino to
let clarence survive Tarantino didn't
want to make the changes so Scott agreed
to film two separate endings one happy
one sad and see which one worked better
no surprise ending here we got the happy
version interstellar love it or hate it
you've got to admit Christopher Nolan's
interstellar is a pretty ambitious
project with a lot of greater visuals
and some interesting ideas of course
there's also that whole love is the one
thing that transcends time and space bit
some fans appreciated the film
sentimental ending while others weren't
so crazy about the sappy message and if
you're someone who likes your sci-fi
served cold then you probably would have
preferred the ending in the original
screenplay
in the finished film to fly straight
into a black hole which allows him to
view the past present and future as one
moment Tube uses his fifth-dimensional
abilities to communicate with his
daughter and save mankind however this
wasn't what screen writer Jonathan Nolan
intended according to Nerdist the
uplifting ending was his brother
Christopher's doing as the screenwriter
explained at a media event after Cooper
enters the black hole the einstein-rosen
bridge colloquially a wormhole would
collapse when Cooper tries to send the
data back in other
words the guy died and mankind most
likely slowly starved into extinction
that's one serious galactic drag and
while we're on the subject of narrowly
avoided intergalactic bombers guardians
of the galaxy
generally speaking the Marvel Cinematic
Universe usually likes to keep things
upbeat at the ends of its movies and
perhaps the happiest ending of all comes
and guardians of the galaxy after
defeating Ronan the accuser star-lord
plugs a new awesome mixtape into the
ship's tape deck and ain't no mountain
high enough plays over a feel-good
montage of all the good guys from the
film
it's an ending specifically designed to
let moviegoers leave with a smile sure
things got super sad when star-lord read
that letter from his mom but at least
he's got a new family now right you know
who's still sad in the lone though Peter
Quill's grandfather originally the old
man was supposed to show up in the
film's final moments which would have
totally killed the Marvin Gaye mood
director James Gunn told slash film it
was grandpa quill and he has this
photograph of Meredith and Peter of a
little boy and he looks up at the stars
when we go up to the stars and it was
really sweet
it means that he must have seen quill
getting abducted at the end of the day
and is still waiting for him to return
but it was freaking sad so we took it
out from park well holding a photo of
his dead daughter still waiting for its
grandson to come back home after all
those years yeah talk about a buzzkill
see you dancing baby Groot
[Music]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're not too
[Music]